I want to give sort of a high level talk
here and talk about the future of
interactive technology pretty broad
topic
but my first thought when I sit down and
think about what is the future of
interactive technology is well it has
changed some over the years that I've
been looking at this
some of the past Futures that we have
had have arrived so we sort of see the
precursor to zoom here and boy has that
arrived in the last few years and that
sort of looks a lot like a Roomba and
this is already on my wrist so some of
these things have definitely that we
wanted to see have definitely arrived
some not so much we do not have jet
packs or flying cars we don't have much
in the way of monorails and certainly
not the sort of cantilevered over the
road thing that I seems to serve no
purpose or Dome cities and I don't know
what that kid was supposed to do but we
don't have that
um but something that did arrive Mark
Weiser had a vision of ubiquitous
Computing where Computing could be sort
of all over
um our lives uh and everywhere and that
Vision has really served us phenomenally
well it's been uh tremendously
insightful we now live in the world
where Computing is really uh accessible
everywhere all right eighty percent of
Americans walk around every day with a
globally connected super computer in
their pocket okay and you can't really
get a whole lot more ubiquit Well you
certainly can get more ubiquitous I'm
going to talk about that
um but that's very ubiquitous okay it's
not exactly what Wiser's Vision was but
it is definitely ubiquitous okay on the
other hand as revolutionary as that was
and as well as it has served us uh in
many respects that Vision was about
taking the Computing that existed uh and
still exists and moving uh the
interactive systems that were there out
into the world okay but I would say we
need to now move beyond that we really
need to think harder about what
interactions need to be like out there
in the world
okay and what they need to look like
given that we have a lot different
technology than we did all right
so today I'm going to take a little
slice out of this very big and hard
topic I and really what I want to do is
to suggest some ways in which I think
you should be thinking a little bit
differently as an HCI researcher about
the future than we have thought about
the future in the past
all right
so I'm not going to try to be in any way
comprehensive and I am surely not going
to try to make any predictions about
where the future is going to be that is
a Fool's errand you're just not even try
um well maybe you should but uh but I am
going to focus on a few things I am
going to talk about some new approaches
to Old problems and I am going to talk
about some old approaches to new
problems all right
and I'm just going to pick three
exemplars and you'll excuse me if I
choose exemplars out of my own work I
understand it the best
um these include some Key properties of
people uh and of sensors and the systems
we all use today and that's going to end
up talking about uncertainty in the
interface
I want to talk a little bit about even
more ubiquity
um and here I want to say that we want
to think about making it even cheaper
and more lightweight smaller inexpensive
than we have in a pretty dramatic sense
and then I want to talk about going
Beyond sort of colonizing the world
that's one way to see Wiser's vision is
colonizing the world the real world with
Computing with the computational world
and I want to go to making the world
actually creating that whole world
all right but before we do that I feel
like for any talk about the future of
technology we really need to talk about
the elephant in the room uh that is
always there okay
and the biggest change I will or I'm
sorry the biggest Agent of Change uh for
us I think uh has actually changed
remarkably little and that is the
exponential growth of computing that is
described by Moore's Law okay now I'm
going to talk about Moore's law in a
very schematic way so you'll notice I've
very carefully labeled one axis here is
good stuff resulting from transistors I
don't know what the met I don't know
what the units on that are and I've
carefully not un labeled time and in
fact that's not an exponential curve at
all it's an ellipse because it's easy to
draw in Powerpoint
but okay but wait you're probably saying
clock speeds stop doubling a long time
ago quite a long time ago isn't Moore's
Law dead well no Moore's Law is not dead
it has been predicted to die any second
now for many many years most of my
lifetime but in fact it goes back
further in time than we think and it
continues forward but there are definite
limitations coming along these days
first off it's much harder to use the
computational power than it used to be
okay so the top seven points in this
chart are all Nvidia gpus okay and
that's a lot harder to get the
computation out of that and doing the
work that you need it to do for your
problem than it is sort of conventional
architectures let's say
but even if we take that out those gpus
out of the picture uh it's still going
on and by the way these to be clear
these charts have a logarithmic scale on
the y-axis so this seemingly linear uh
increase here is actually exponential so
even without gpus these are all
conventional CPUs this starts starting
to get a little bit old but it's pretty
close to what's happening now we're it's
still going on
okay but the doubling rate is probably
going to get wider longer it's been
doubling at two years it's probably
going to be longer it's going to be less
less consistent it's not going to be so
clock step uh as it has been okay it's
going to be less predictable but it is
still happening
all right and so what I like to say is
Moore's law is dead Long Live Moore's
Law
all right now
I know what you're thinking it's like
why are you telling me this I have known
about Moore's Law since I was 12 years
old why do you why are you telling me
about this okay I am here today to try
to convince you that you do not
understand Moore's Law okay and it
really does matter
um and you should be thinking about it a
lot more as an HCI researcher as
somebody who's building technology for
people to use I think we need to think a
lot more about Moore's Law and more
about the computational power than we
have
okay and the reason for that I will say
you don't understand Moore's Law is
because it is very difficult as human
beings to understand exponential growth
it's just it's nearly impossible it
seems to me every time I think I
understand it I realize I don't
okay and that will come up in the talk
in a bit here okay and so I want to give
you two thought experiments to help you
understand this exponential growth
um that it's described by Moore's law
all right first one first thought
experiment number one all right think
about all the computational in increase
in computational power that we've had
since you can pick a date but I'll pick
1965 and maybe this is what Computing
looked like in about 1965 very different
than today that's a machine that fills a
good part of a room which is vastly
overpowered by my watch okay so think
about just how much increase there's
been this tremendous explosion of
increased computational power holding
your head a second how much increase
that is
right well what does it mean to double
every two years it means all of that
increase every single bit of it happens
again in the next two years all of it
all of that increase happens again
that's what doubling means and this is
why we can't understand exponential
increases
okay that is huge okay every single bit
of those gains are going to happen in
the next two years every single bit are
going to happen before sophomores in
this room graduate okay all of that
change is going to happen again
all right it's all going to happen for
the professors before your next seven SF
Grant expires
okay should you ever get one
I've been struggling with that
um
all right thought experiment number two
now this thought experiment comes from
Douglas Engelbert I saw him delivered at
one point
it's a great experiment suppose you and
everything in this room so we can't
really see outside this room that's
great for this experiment uh suppose you
and everything in the room here suddenly
got 10 times bigger could you tell the
difference all right how many people
think you can tell you could not tell
the difference
I think that's kind of the Common Sense
answers you couldn't quite tell the
difference that turns out to be the
right answer but for not the reason that
you think okay so let's think about this
a little bit
um let's see how our chairs situated
here we have two legs okay
um well first off Mass scales by volume
but the strength of the chair that
you're sitting in now scales by the
cross-sectional area of those posts that
are holding you up those two posts and
so suddenly you have 10 times the amount
of weight proportionally you wait
essentially a ton and those chairs are
not designed for that and the chair is
going to collapse under that weight and
you might notice that okay all right
so the chair will collapse under the 10x
weight but in fact that you're probably
going to be distracted you're not going
to notice that because most of your
bones are going to break for exactly the
same reason okay and you will you will
probably notice that okay
except not really uh because oxygen
consumption of cells scales by volume
but their ability to absorb at Scales by
area you just lost 90 percent of your
oxygen to your brain you will be
unconscious before you hit the floor and
dead shortly thereafter so no you won't
notice
okay but not for the reason that you
thought
all right so the moral of the story here
is that large and in this case this is
an order of magnitude change but if you
think about things doubling we're
talking about a lot more than a more or
more uh order of magnitude change order
of magnitude and large or larger changes
have a huge impact on things and they in
particular have a big impact when we
have differential scaling which is
exactly what we've got we've got sort of
raw computing power on this end that is
scaling very very rapidly exponentially
and we've got the important part of the
system and the complicated part of the
system the human beings down here which
proportionally just aren't scaling at
all aren't changing and everything in
between there so we have a huge amount
of differential scaling and this thought
experiment is really to make you realize
that when you have big differential
scaling it has huge impacts on things
all right
now by the way just how much computing
power do we have right now because I
think we lose track of this so
um see last time I did this I looked
this up in the latest uh Nvidia
architecture
um
we're talking about 76 billion
transistors on each chip okay and
billion is a number that's a little hard
like exponential is a little hard to get
your head around so let's talk about
that a little bit first off it's getting
kind of hard to measure these days
because you've got so many you now have
a bunch of different core types but I
think we likely have about a hundred
trillion so we've just bounced up by
another factor of a thousand floating
Point operations per second at Peak
speeds for a single GPU and these are
devices you can buy off the shelf stuff
into your PC these are not anything sort
of fancy or in a research lab somewhere
okay and to give you an idea of how big
that is that comes out to roughly 1100
floating Point operations per second for
every single neuron in your brain
all right
so it should beg the question of like
can I simulate a neuron with 1100
floating Point operations per second I
think you probably can but different
talk okay
all right uh also in this architecture
we have uh 18
000 separate cores or they're not all
independent some of them have chunks of
them have to be executing the same
instruction but as a comparison all of
this started out with micro controllers
or I'm sorry microcomputers and the
original uh microcomputer had 2300
transistors in it so we have many we
have an order of magnitude more cores
this is at least an ALU in each one of
those then we had transistors in where
we in the micro computer that kind of we
feel like started all of this
all right so that is a huge amount of
computing power
but the really interesting thing about
exponential growth and about Moore's Law
is that nothing has happened yet okay we
feel like there's been all this
technological change in the last few
years and things have just been
exploding nothing has happened yet
because we are here we are not way up
here we are here at the beginning uh and
that's an implication of exponential
growth okay if you think about I said in
two years we're going to see all of that
change that I said was there or that you
thought about was there since 1965 again
in four years we're going to have seen
three times that much and so forth and
so on okay and so the change that we've
seen recently or seems like recently
that seems like it's just exploding
nothing
uh it's just a drop in the bucket
compared to what we're going to see uh
as things continue on
Okay so
hopefully that gives you an idea that
maybe we have a lot of raw material to
work with and we can expect a lot more
raw material in the future so what are
we going to do with that from an HCI
perspective how are we going to serve
people for this okay and here I'm just
going to throw out some possible a few
possible exemplars and I'll basically
setting up the first one here
um
here's some ideas of things we might do
these are not in all new ideas or
original to me
one is sensor sensors and more sensors
and let's use machine learning to derive
the context of interaction so that we
know what the user is doing and we can
respond appropriately and we can provide
value for that okay see a lot of that
out in the world another one is let's do
natural interaction so gesture and
speech and other things that we do in
human to human communication to make our
interaction with uh our machines more
natural okay well what do those things
have in common
right uh something they have in common
is uncertainty and this is something
they have in common that we are is not
in common with our previous work
okay and uncertainty so now we don't
know exactly what we've got okay
we don't know that the sensors are
accurate we definitely don't know that
the machine learning models have
definitely delivered the truth they're
getting much and much much much much
better but they're you know you think
about it 95 accuracy you're still
missing one in 20 getting it wrong okay
if you think about what we know about
how to handle input if it was the case
that you know I was told my system
reported an event that the left Mouse
button went down but one out of 20 it
didn't really
that would make building interfaces
really hard but that is what we were
dealing with uh when we introduced
uncertainty and in fact all of what we
know not all of what we know but almost
all what we know in the structure that
we have built for handling inputs is
really uh implicitly assuming that the
inputs actually happened as they deliver
and were delivered and if that's not
true then all sorts of bad things start
to happen and so this uncertainty is a
is a real problem and it's been a real
problem for quite a long time
okay and so this brings me to my example
our number one uh that I want to talk
about which is handling uncertain
interaction okay now for me this is an
old problem it's a very time still a
completely timely problem I think but
I've been trying to work on this problem
for more than 30 years uh across three
uh
three PhD students uh great work over 30
years
um
but we somewhat recently uh well I guess
2014 is somewhat recently
um a new we finally sort of got to my
feeling that we had made some
significant progress on this uh problem
and basically Julia Schwartz here uh
building on on my other students Jen
mankoff and then before that Gary Newell
um was able to sort of essentially crack
this or at least provide a big move
forward by using a massive amount of
computing power and well we'll see if
it's really massive in a minute but I I
let's call it massive for a minute okay
so what did she do
um well what she ended up doing was to
use Monte Carlo representations of the
interface and a particle filtering
approach to consider multiple
Alternatives now if you think about
inputs or you think about uncertainty
and interaction you have uncertainty in
the input you don't know what you have
so you want to think about a probability
distribution over the possible inputs
that maybe this really was and that's
going to induce uh probability
distribution Over States of the
interface
okay and so what we're really going to
do is or what Julia did was to run and
copies as many as you need of the
interface so now each of these copies is
represented by internally by an
interactor tree if you know how
interfaces are uh uh implemented
internally and each copy of that each
copy of that interface tree represents
one possible state of the interface and
we have a collection of them we can use
that collection as an approximation to
the probability distribution over the
possible states that have been induced
by the possible states of the input okay
so each copy is a sample
of a possible state in a very high
dimensional State space of interfaces
okay
all right so together uh these samples
approximate this large probability
distribution
and it is the probability distribution
of probable probability of states that
have been induced by the probability
that we saw particular inputs okay
all right well this is unfortunately the
part of the talk where I have to do True
Confessions
which is I don't understand Moore's Law
either okay Julia cracked this by doing
something that I characterize at the
time as crazy I told her not to do it in
fact she implemented a whole system
under my advice that didn't take this
Approach at all and it didn't it worked
okay but it wasn't that great
um
eventually she stopped listening to me
but I was I was telling her we will need
thousands of copies of interfaces as I
said there's n copies that were going on
and this will never be practical I said
don't do this I said well she
implemented on her mobile phone and it
worked just fine
so yeah I don't understand Moore's Law
either
um why is it that this is okay uh why
doesn't this combinatorically explode
well particle filtering is designed to
keep the particles under control but you
still think you're going to need
thousands of these but that's fine okay
if you think about it uh the structures
that we use for implementing graphical
user interfaces today were invented in
the early 80s they work great on the
machines at that time we now have over
200 000 times more computational power
more memory more of everything than we
had at that time so if we need 20 000
copies of the interface it's just a drop
in the bucket okay no problem
we can do that
so
that's why we need to pay attention to
this and then it turns out you don't
need thousands of copies and this is not
something that we understood or learned
until we implemented it
but uh you don't need thousands of
samples you might need a hundred samples
you probably don't usually you need tens
of samples
Julia said I'm going to cap this at 10
samples and it worked fine for the demo
that I'll show in a minute okay why is
that
this is a very high dimensional space
how can we possibly sample it well the
reason is that the high dimensionality
here
um
the dimensions are in just not at all
independent of each other and if you
think about what the user's doing uh
there's only probably three or four
maybe five but usually three or four
things that the user might be trying to
do at any given time so you don't need
that many samples to really represent
that and the truth of the matter is if
there's a hundred things that they might
be trying to do right now what should be
the system's response well the system
needs to say I don't know what's going
on here okay and so mostly it's just
going to throw up its hands at that
point and we're never going to get to
thousands as an as a necessity for
modeling this so it turns out that we
could have afforded to do tens of
thousands of interfaces we only need to
do 10 okay but we never got we would
have never gotten there to understand
that point if uh Julia had listened to
me
um
okay so the moral of the story is do
what I said no wait that's not right
um the moral of the story is that the
siren song of efficiency that comes from
our computer science intuitions and we
all have these intuitions when I sit
down and write code it's like I never
write inefficient code I always think
right there about okay what's the
efficient way to do this what's the
efficient way to do that those
intuitions are coming to us from the
past from a long time ago okay and some
of them are still perfectly valid but
some of them are not as much as we think
okay and the siren song of those
instincts is strong and as HCI
researchers I think a lot of the time we
need to work hard to overcome those and
that was part of the the real reason I
wanted to talk a bit about Moore's Law
up front or part of the reason
okay now by the way what are we going to
do with these probability distributions
that uh Julia built here well the
original aims of my work back in the 90s
was to do things like accurately track
and reason about the Alternatives the
uncertain set of Alternatives that might
be there okay to be able to make
informed judgments about what is
happening but under uncertainty okay and
a probability distribution is going to
help you a lot with that you have some
notion of well yeah these two things
these two things are possible or
probable right now but one of them is
way more probable than the other you're
going to do one thing but if it's like
this is just barely more probable than
the other uh maybe you're going to need
to act differently okay and so those
probability distributions are very
important
okay and particularly we don't want to
let uh recognition errors that happen
early uh break our interactions and this
is a lot of what happens with uncertain
systems is you have to act on the basis
of what you've got and you got to make
early decisions and if there's one uh
recognition error early it can basically
take you straight off into the weeds and
things crash okay and you need to defer
those kinds of decisions until you have
enough information and know when you
have less uncertainty you have enough or
you have a low enough uncertain to be
able to act appropriately
okay and then we also want to be able to
provide feedback to the user about the
uncertainty that the system has the user
is probably not uncertain at all they
know what they're doing the system
doesn't know but being able to somehow
feedback to the user that I the system
doesn't get what you're doing right now
isn't immensely valuable in this setting
and again we need some model of the
uncertainty to do that probability
distributions are good all right so let
me show you a little video
um
which is a demo of sort of the end
product here
ah there we go consider this touch
diagramming tool inspired by igarashi's
Interactive beautification
I'm actually going to stop this for a
second so there's something missing here
this is a fairly conventional drawing
tool as you'll see you can draw lines
and and Primitives and it's going to do
a little of straightening up here but
what's missing in this picture
there's no palette
there's no set of operators here you
just do it
okay you just draw the thing that you
want out there and but that drawing is
going to be very ambiguous when you
start the drawing you can't tell if
you're drawing a circle or a square or a
line all right uses that shapes the
canvas by dragging out a bounding region
multiple shapes are possible the
application guess is the most likely
shape based on past actions when the
user hesitates the application shows an
embestlist highlighting changes the user
may then select an alternative by
tapping on it
shapes and lines may be dragged when an
item is being dragged a trash can
appears the bottom of the screen
dragging to this area removes the item
of course if the user just wants to put
the item at the bottom of the screen she
can select this alternative as well in
addition to being dragged shapes can
also be resized when adjusting lines
endpoints snapped targets
here is a demonstration of the features
of this application
such an application would be very
difficult to implement in a conventional
interface framework
with our framework both the tracking of
interface Alternatives and the rendering
of these alternatives to communicate
uncertainty are handled by the system
interface developers only need to worry
about specifying the operational logic
of interactors and about rendering a
single alternative to the screen
okay now that last bit is really
important as well so as a programmer of
this system you don't really think much
about uncertainty at all there's tiny
little bit of things that you need to
add to this mostly you write the one
interface that is based on a certain POS
you know on certain input we run
multiple copies of it and combine things
back together but as a programmer you
don't have to think about that you just
write the interface like you would have
written it as if there was not on
certain Interpol so that's also very
important as a result here
no no no no
all right
there we go now
what else could we possibly do uh when
we've got probability distribution so
there's a bunch of other stuff we can do
but there are some future possibilities
I want to talk about as well so maybe
there's a PhD number four somewhere down
there uh these have been about 20 years
apart and we're probably not going to
get to get down to number four but maybe
all right one thing we could do is zero
latency interfaces
okay and cut latency down to nothing how
do we do that well if we have a
probability distribution of what's going
on maybe we can figure out the three to
five most thing or three to ten it says
here most things most probable things
and just go out and compute the results
that we do in some sort of reversible
fashion for each of those and have them
ready and they're sitting there and as
soon as we get far enough in that we
know what the user wants and they have
told us what they want boom it's there
no latency
okay and in fact we can turn that dial a
little further we can do negative
latency interfaces okay we can know
before the user tells us what they want
to do what they want to do uh with with
some probability
and if we were to provide appropriate
interaction techniques now this is going
to require definitely some new
interaction techniques
uh to do this but if we can do
appropriate interaction techniques we
can provide things faster
um and get things done with essentially
negative latency which is an interesting
concept
okay so I decided we're going to do
three exemplars let's move to number two
can we be even more ubiquitous than we
are today okay and I think at this next
level
um a lot of at least simple ubiquitous
tests are going to need devices which
are almost disposable I kind of don't
want disposable devices I want
recyclable devices but let's think about
disposable like we would think about
disposing of a piece of paper because
that's how we're going to do it okay can
we make it paper-like can we make
interactive useful interactive devices
for 20 cents let's say okay not tens of
dollars not hundreds of dollars 20 cents
can we do that and of course I'm gonna
say the answer is yeah we can do that
um
so we can do computation at this price
point in case you missed it these days
you can buy a micro controller for three
cents you have to buy them in quantity
of 100 but why wouldn't you okay
um so yes we can provide computation but
that's not gonna that seemed like you
know one of the big hurdles to getting
under 20 cents but not anymore
all right but we need to remember that
Moore's law is great but not everything
scales uh the way Moore's Law does the
way transistors have scaled in
particular we I think we all know
batteries do not scale uh in that way
they've been scaling much more linearly
okay
and so it's not the computation it's not
having a computer anymore that's the
problem it's power okay but it turns out
that there are some interesting
corollaries to Moore's Law
um and several of these uh Josh Smith at
the University of Washington who did a
bunch of has done and is doing a bunch
of good work in this area taught me and
one of them is that smaller transistors
are also reducing power they're lower
power
um
and so our power consumption is going
down very rapidly
um
so can we go without batteries because
either supplying the batteries or
running the wire to the wall or changing
the batteries is not going to work for
20 cent devices they're not going to
work for being way more ubiquitous than
we are so it's not a new observation
can we go without power in the device at
all
at all okay and the answer is fairly
straightforward
you can think about is it possible
because yeah we're already doing this
you already have this you're carrying
with you now cards that have in them
RFID tags and these tags don't have uh
Power in them but they have a little bit
of computation
and it turns out as we'll see in just a
second we can turn these into
interactive devices okay and this is a
very widely deployed as I say you all
have one or more of these with you I
have several in my wallet and my credit
cards and my ID to get me in the door
and things like that
um
now these are relying on an external
power support Source there's a reader
which is supplying RF energy through the
air just enough to get us over uh the
threshold to be able to power a little
bit of electronics and to be able to
commute and not importantly communicate
back and forth okay but we could also
possibly think uh that we could do this
without any external power at all
uh by doing ambient Backscatter
signaling techniques so there's RF
energy coming uh through this space
constantly probably from all our phones
if nothing else Wi-Fi TV radio uh
there's a small bit of power there and
you can pull out a small bit of that
power not probably not enough well there
are in some cases is enough to actually
run a computation but we don't
necessarily need to do that what we can
think about for these kinds of devices
is using the mechanical manipulation of
the device to manipulate the properties
of an antenna the change is the way it
absorbs or reflects backscatters uh
ambient radio frequency information
that's already there and then read that
at a distance okay so it's possible that
we can do things without uh interesting
devices without having any power on the
device at all or even power in an
external reader well you're going to
need a little been in the receiver I
guess okay
so can we do this so again a couple of
now re very recently graduated PhD
students have been working on some parts
of this
and again to look at interactive devices
where the user's action the mechanical
action of the user reconfigures an
antenna in this case an antenna that is
literally printed on paper
and we connect or disconnect elements of
that antenna for example okay so then
that opens up in a bunch of interesting
questions of how how do we make these
how do we interact with them what kind
of devices are possible
okay
so now to give you a look at what might
be possible I'm going to rewind a little
bit and back to a project that I did in
collaboration uh with my colleagues at
Disney research Pittsburgh back when
that existed particularly uh a Lansing
sample who was actually Josh Smith's PhD
student who knows a ton about RF and
wireless power and yeah he taught me
what little I know about it he knows a
lot so we did an interesting project
there and there's a nice demo video here
with typical high production values from
Disney that shows you what's possible
and these are done with RFID off the
shelf RFID tags with an embedded antenna
and RFID circuit
we print antennas using silver
nanoparticle inks from an inkjet printer
and add a small sticker with the RFID IC
similar to the printed tags a conductive
ink pen is used to trace custom tags
through a stencil
a pen can also be used to draw freehands
these are combined together to make a
palette of RFID interaction Primitives
that can be used as building blocks for
end applications
we sense seven different basic
interaction methods including covering
touching
sliding
turning
swiping
tag movement
and hand waving
this pop-up book triggers sound effects
from a nearby computer when the page is
opened and when the wheel is rotated two
different positions
[Music]
hahaha
in this application a single sheet of
paper can be rolled into a conductor's
wand and the user can control the rhythm
of the music
a tag on a pinwheel acts as a wind speed
sensor and can be coupled with on-screen
animations like these particles
in the dollhouse a single button tag
triggers the doorbell the slider
controls the lights in the different
rooms
here we show a lamp being controlled by
RFID tag interactions
in this classroom polling application
students can answer questions live
during class with buttons embedded in
the same worksheet they are writing on
thank you
all right so that gives you a good idea
of sort of a vocabulary of things no no
there we go we use sticker like
there yes
waving thing work there are two tags and
we look at the differential signal
strength uh between the return from
those two tags
uh and then there's a bit of a simple
machine learning underneath that to look
for that particular interaction
so how does that so tag is completing a
um okay so the tag is talking to a
reader off screen not shown five hundred
dollars
uh not not quite that much but it's an
expensive thing which is why I talked a
little bit about ambient Backscatter but
uh there's a reader off screen which is
uh introducing RF uh and uh inducing
enough power in the tag that it
basically can manip do electronic
manipulation of its antenna and
basically turn turn
um
absorption high and low of that antenna
and if you think about like high or low
that's going to get you one and you can
sense that from the reader that's going
to get you one bit and then you build a
huge protocol on top of icons I can
transmit one bit
the reader is not on the screen is not
shown it's off to the side but we but
the readers that we were using here in
uh these are ultra high frequency tags
have a uh three practical you can
definitely do three meter uh reading so
you could put it up at the ceiling and
sort of look down sometimes we put it
under the table or we just sit it off to
the side
and where's the transmission
where's the train it's coming from the
reader that
so I'm sorry say it again so so what
does the silver tag do there uh it
communicates back an identification and
so one of the things that's happening is
we are if you put your finger on things
that may be causing a tag to either
start or stop operating and so it will
start or stop
um producing its identification to the
reader and then we can translate all
that into we know which tags are in
which piece of the device and we can
translate all that all into user
interface actions
all right
[Applause]
all right so there is a fairly going
back to the high level here there is a
fairly simple classical lesson here
which is new technology
RFID tags actually are not that new but
the ambient Backscatter might be yeah
the hand basically
um the right way to think about it is
interfering with the level of signal
that you get between the reader and the
tag and so and one of the things I can
read is not just the ID but I can read
an RSS which is receive signal strength
and I can see that going up and down in
a systematic way and if I've got two of
them I can compare them
yes the reader sends and also senses how
much of the RF energy that it is sending
gets absorbed by the tag versus
scattered somewhere else
the light yeah but it's better to think
about it in an absorption because
reflection goes in all sorts of
directions uh the absorption is
it's a receiver that's
um
yeah the reader Bowl sends and sends an
RF signal and senses how much of that
signal it has been absorbed by the world
versus reflected back
yeah okay so simple classic lesson here
which is new technology
uh or existing technology pushed in New
Directions is what we really have here
can push the boundaries of problems that
we used to be working on in new and
interesting ways this is something that
in the West Community is like bread and
butter we're constantly looking for new
technology which allows us to solve old
problems okay and so this is new
solutions to Old problems
so now I want to go to Exemplar number
three
and here I want to talk about going
beyond the UB comp notion of colonizing
the world with computation
and I want to talk about
a new capability of actually making the
world with computation
and this is probably what I'm most
excited about from research directions
these days which is new digital
manufacturing
capabilities 3D printing is the one of
these that is probably most common in
people's minds
okay
these are starting to make it possible
to fabricate a really wide range of
objects based on things that we design
in the virtual world so we can think of
a design we can draw it on the screen
but purely virtually we push a button
and it appears well it's never that
simple as somebody who 3D prints all the
time it's not just pressing a button but
there is a path to get me from my
computational representation to an
actualized physical object the shape of
the silver print
what does that have to do with the
receiving
um it's gonna it's gonna change the the
silver shape is an antenna and you're
going to change the end the antennas
properties most most of the time we're
talking about Shifting the resonant
frequency
and so the shape there is designed to
resonate at a particular frequency the
tag wants to work at a particular
frequency if you shift the operation of
the antenna away from that resonant
frequency it doesn't work anymore and
the ID disappears so that's one way and
that we manipulate it but that's what
the shape matters because it changes the
resonant frequency of the antenna
and so manipulating that shape like
adding a new piece to it will change its
resonant frequency and change whether it
reports or not
all right so lots of folks including me
are working on new types of materials
and printers okay doing all sorts of
interesting new stuff uh there is a lot
of really interesting work to do there
lots of interesting things we can do now
and there's a tremendous growth in what
we can print and in fact my favorite is
down at the bottom here this is Adam
feinberg's at cme's work this is a 3D
printed piece of collagen that is the
sort of the scaffolding for a human
heart valve you can basically populate
this with cells
and so it's 3D printing of a human heart
that's one of the things that's what
Adam's real goal is and I have to say
that you know the best and coolest thing
I could possibly think to print is spare
parts for me okay
but I would say that in addition to this
sort of expansion of what we can do
these days
um there's much more potential Advance
by taking a very classic HCI approach
and that is to enable a much wider set
of users to make use of a very powerful
technology okay and we can see this from
the past from a lesson that was a very
major success which is desktop
publishing okay and we don't really use
that word very much anymore but uh very
old-fashioned but a lot of modern
graphical user interfaces really came
out of solving this problem or producing
this thing which was desktop publishing
all right so once upon a time creating a
high quality document was the domain I
was sure it's exclusive domain of a
certain set of professionals typesetters
uh book designers that sort of stuff
okay and desktop publishing came along
and changed that it made it so everybody
can produce reasonably high quality
documents
all right but much more importantly than
our ability to produce documents was
really all of the things that came with
that that were unimagined so the goal
was to be able to make it so we could
produce documents that's what Xerox Park
was trying to do with the star and the
precursors to that
but what was really interesting was all
the stuff that happened as a result of
that capability a lot a lot of what we
see sort of on our desktop today and
which is going again migrated to our
phones and tablets came out of the
solution to that problem but it was not
completely expected and definitely the
details of that were not what was
necessarily expected okay
and we are I feel like we're in a
similar situation today or we can see an
analogy so the technology is there and
it's affordable for 200 bucks you can
buy a printer a 3D printer that will
print quite well
um actually a prints as good as the
printer we had bought sort of maybe a
decade before that that cost thirty
thousand dollars
but the problem is that the design of
functional objects if you go to
functional objects as opposed to like
baby Yodas
requires a lot of skill all right
uh and it requires a lot of skill in
different areas including 3D modeling
but it goes well beyond that uh you need
a lot of knowledge of materials strength
of materials
um
mechanical design all sorts of stuff
like that uh which we can boil down to
something called an engineering degree
okay
um or something similar all right so
this makes all this making this more
accessible to a wider set of folks makes
this an HCI problem okay I think some
people have questions weather
fabrication is an HCI problem it's an
HCI problem
okay really doing what we want to do so
if we can abstract and encapsulate these
capabilities we can produce a revolution
uh in making of things which I think can
parallel the kind of Revolution that we
saw in desktop publishing uh because
really we're talking about much more
capable things it's not just stuff on
paper anymore that we're going to create
but it's physical objects much more
functional
all right so that's my pitch for why you
should pay attention to that now why
does this have to do with Moore's Law
okay well an important approach to
making this happen is going to be in
generative design and in particular
interactive generative design so we've
seen a lot of work in generative design
but often it is sort of very batch
oriented you sort of specify and by the
way generated design you're going to
specify what you want but not how to
achieve that all the details of that and
we're going to let the system produce
the design we're going to let the system
generate that but a lot of current
generative design is very essentially
batch oriented you say what you want it
produces a design you take it or leave
it okay uh if you want if you don't like
it you have to go back and change your
description of what you wanted okay you
can't really interact with it okay
now a lot of generative design gets done
through optimization and it turns out
optimization is very capable of
consuming every bit of CPU power that we
can deliver to it today but remember
what's coming okay
so uh we are now starting to see enough
computational power
um that we can start to think about
using this in an interactive setting
where the user really interacts with the
process
which means we have to run at very fast
rates we have to run at interactive
rates not sort of in a Bad setting all
right so here's an example this is from
Anthony Chen's dissertation work so
we're going to start with an example
here we want to design this uh lag on
this quadruped robot it needs to touch
the ground here and have enough strength
to hold that leg and we're going to
provide a force here all right and we're
going to have a little simple tool we're
going to say Well it kind of is going to
be from here to here we're going to have
this much force here and it's going to
be touching the ground down here now
these are all interactive elements so
he's going to go in here and erase a
little part of this other while he's
pointing to the operators but we'll
erase part of that and then we'll put it
back okay
and then based on this sketch and the
loading scenario that's in this sketch
we're gonna have the system generate and
this as we start here we'll speed this
up later but this is now in real time
we're going to have the system generate
uh a design so this is if you know about
this this is topology optimization here
these are all going to end up being
variations on topology optimization and
there are three kinds of variations on
topology optimization I just showed you
one here's another one which is
variations on the existing design so you
can see the user sort of gave part of it
and then the system comes along and says
you need to add this in order to meet
those requirements that you have set up
here
um
and number three says okay stay Within
These bounds so you may be this thing
has to attach to something else or it
needs to not hit something stay Within
These bounds produce something that has
very high strength to weight ratio is
what we're basically looking for here
okay now there's also an interactive
element more interactive element to this
we can come along and say well I want
this to be more similar to what I had
before or less similar to what I've
drawn so this is a high similarity one
and we're going to just take that slider
and say well okay you go you can go a
little further from what I said and
you'll see it produces a little bit
different design that is further from
what the user originally specified and
and all of our designs are sort of the
possible designs are stacked up there
and we can select them and so forth
okay and you can also come in and edit
and say well I don't want so much
material here and this isn't just like
saying you can't put material here this
is really a hint to the system and the
optimizer that I want less material
there I want less material there and you
can see it goes back and tries to do
that you can also come in and say I want
more material here okay so he's going to
come in and draw say I think there
should be material here and the system
really comes back and says well no you
don't really need that
and but then the user can come and say
yeah really I want more material there
and so the system comes back and says
all right I'll put a little more
material there
um okay so these are really hints uh to
the system they are not sort of
commanding that it must be like this so
here's an example of the full use of
this now unfortunately right now
computationally we can only really do
this in 2D and I think that's true of
everybody and but we're going to do a
bicycle seat here okay and 3D print that
bicycle seat and we're going to sit on
it in a second here
there we go all right that's our demo
bike that we have in the lab that we use
for many different purposes
um okay here's another example which is
we're going to make
I'm going to make a little table
okay and we need strong uh legs for that
but
um don't necessarily want them to just
be solid
so here's the physical instantiation of
that result as a little table
all right and lots of other things but
we're gonna
stop at this point and move on
really there we go all right so the
lesson that I want to sort of bring
forward with this is that the big win
here is going to have come from
empowering a lot of new people this is a
classic
HCI theme applied to a new area Okay
empowering a set of people and this will
likely result uh in a wide set of really
great but really unexpected results I
think all right
so let me wrap this up since I am in
fact running late implications of all
this
how should you be thinking differently
as an HCI researcher well I think one of
the ways in which you should be thinking
differently is that you need to be think
you are not thinking big enough with
respect to how much computing power you
can put into the interface in service of
the user we need to think bigger now
it's the case that order n cubed and
worse algorithms are still not going to
work okay don't forget that all right
but a lot of what we do does not fit in
that and our CSN tuition is about
efficiency are really getting us into
trouble they are leading us astray all
right so I think you really want to
think in terms of
just burning CPU Cycles in in service of
the user not for no reason at all and
not just burning them because I'm a CS
person I don't want to be a fish
inefficient but we want to think about
really a lot applying a lot more
computing power than we have
all right now I'm almost done
our HCI and I want to say that our I
don't want to just pick on my CS
intuitions I think our HCI intuitions
are getting us into trouble too
okay and my favorite example of that is
this here which is a picture from Steve
feiner's touring project 1997. all right
what do we have here we have this
personal sort of suited up in this get
up first off we can look at this and say
is that usable no not even close
um but what do we got here well this
sort of Dome shape thing on the end of
the pole is what you had to do for GPS
at that point uh there is a really big
laptop strapped to that backpack so a
mobile computation there was a handheld
display with input this was pen input at
that time because that's what we thought
was going to be good and that's what we
had uh and then there's this
experimental Wireless communication what
does all that put together make
okay makes a smartphone all right and so
we need to remember that in order uh for
us to get that smartphone we need to do
this okay to do this we need to do that
to get that there's much more that we
need to do but we need to be able to do
that and that's not usable so our HCI
intuitions of we need to take this out
to the users and see if they can use it
for the task okay no
all right we need to be able to explore
things before that and so our sort of
methodologies and our intuitions from
HCI are also getting us into trouble so
I think there's a second order lesson
here which is our methodologies that we
use for all sorts of things are very
well evolved
and they are evolved to suit the values
and needs of a particular context and a
particular time
all right
now the fact of the matter is that
because they are evolved they serve that
context and that time very well but
we need to keep in mind uh that these
tend to get passed on not uh sort of in
a very
um considered way but they get passed on
as the right thing to do
methodologically you learn from your
advisor as a PhD student the right way
to do research and that encapsulates a
set of evolved methodologies that serve
a particular set of values very well and
these also get passed on from reviewers
to authors once you start authoring
papers you'll understand this
but again they get passed on as the
right way to do things without a lot of
examination and I say that this is
getting us into trouble and it
particular gets us into trouble in an
interdisciplinary setting where we have
multiple possible sets of values
multiple possible contexts multiple
possible goals HCI clearly is in in that
setting and especially when things are
changing very fast
and my whole thought experiments around
Moore's Law is pushing towards things
are changing very fast
okay but most of all I want you to come
away remember ing that you are here
all the cool and good stuff hasn't
happened yet all the big changes in
front of you it is not behind you okay
and with that I am overtime and we'll
stop I don't know what I should do about
questions
oh
[Applause]
I only take one question from someone
who hasn't spoken yet
don't want to use up the one slot
all right go for it uh he's gonna hand
you the microwave they're gonna hand you
bikes
um based on just uh
uh based on just um everything that's
been discovered up till now and just um
your personal experience of the research
that you've done
um what would you say like the biggest
like like what would you say is the
biggest advancement or where the world
is going now in terms of just um
technology human interaction okay well I
won't roll my slides back but remember
at the beginning I said I'm not making
predictions
but but I will go ahead and make the
prediction uh okay I'm you know I'm just
gonna make the personal prediction well
I'll change your question into like what
am I working on what do I think what am
I putting you know I've only got one of
me what am I putting that resource on
and right now it is fabrication
um there's a bunch of interesting things
I think we can do with new computational
fabrication techniques I don't believe
that's the answer to that question but
it's the answer that I use for myself uh
for the most part right now now the
truth of the matter is I work on all
sorts of different things and I'm
interested in working on all sorts of
things I don't really believe a lot in
planning of research less so than other
people
um so anyway that's my answer take it or
leave it
thanks all right thank you Scott
[Applause]